peu
chaud
s'ils m'avaient chance
etc
[Musique]
oui
m
[Musique]
dansant
oh et
oui
hu
[Applaudissements]
k
salah
ça
[Musique]
la seconde chance
ça
[Musique]
j'aide ans
vous
toi rafael torres et
[Musique]
calé
c'est mal
là
[Musique]
ça
tha
au bout
allez
ça
[Musique]
jusqu'à la fin
quand je chante
là
en chanson
[Musique]
là
grandes chansons
[Musique]
on trouvait ça cool
ces mêmes
mais c'est tout
[Musique]
blanche m
couvert d
c'est pour
le nul ne dit que tu peux faire
messieurs les vpn
[Musique]
je
je n'ai plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas
[Musique]
et
je ne sais pas
[Musique]
et toi
à voir
[Musique]
non
ce matin
ce
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
je tapais
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
auj
et
je me serais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
/
tuân
main
[Musique]
e
je suis
[Applaudissements]
si seuls que
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu vois
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mon jeu
[Musique]
je veux que tous
la poule
la cour
je
[Musique]
t
je prends
non
[Applaudissements]
e
m
sur le coup
c'est long
[Musique]
je vais
[Applaudissements]
penser
je me sens
m
du moment
oh
on y est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il faudrait
tous les gens qui sont le temps
voilà
avec
[Musique]
de saison
dimanche m
nous
temps réel
allah
pour
[Musique]
non pas du tout
sur rai
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on aime
il faudrait me donner à moi comme autant
d'elle
lyon 2
cd
un jour de joie pour tes mais comme je
t'ai humain
du temps
obama
le pire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la nuit
m
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ayo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
c'est beau
[Musique]
m
il
oui
moi je vais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
il faut savoir
encore sourire
[Musique]
russell
ekin est
le pire
dans une vie fait pleurer
il faut se
en
te coûte
[Musique]
gardez tout seul
pour
qui
[Musique]
sans se tourner
qui nous désole
1 et devant
[Musique]
car c'est là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il faut savourer
quitter la table
lorsque l'amour et essai
[Musique]
sans s'accrocher leur pitoyable
mais partir
faire de bruit il faut savoir
chez sa poubelle
simon
que de tous
jours
tenir les cris
qui
ces derniers mois
photo ap
et pourtant
[Musique]
bon
des mots
mais
il faut pas
à
[Musique]
bah
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai toujours les cheveux
et si
dans
chantant des chansons
[Musique]
j'aime les hommes
bah
coeur joie
je vois là
vous non
[Musique]
et je vis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
v
[Musique]
cher
j'ai
[Applaudissements]
oh
que
et
j'ai toujours
l'amour là
yma
sa voix
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
jamais
[Musique]
je m'appelle
j'ai le coeur
j'ai
je
[Musique]
le dieu
le coeur
[Musique]
mes chers
michèle torr elle vous a vous tous je
suis une petite française
lee
et dans les magazines
je ne lis pas mal
je suis une provinciale
je n'ai pas lu parce qu'elle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
corrigés
[Musique]
quand
un papa les épouses à la chanson ne
changea pas son
hélas
voilà
vous aujourd'hui une petite française
néant
loin de sous
d'enfants
tu attends suis apte à lui 1
raison de quitter sort
raison pour ce tout
devant
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
je ne suis pas une idole qu'on avait
compte des données
je vis mes années
[Musique]
toujours loire de paris
que sans avoir dans
suivirent pas bien je crois
quand je vois quelques gosses
toujours autour de moi
il
[Musique]
quand
t'as pas les épouses à la chanson
ne changea pas 100
aujourd'hui
une petite française néant
loin de ces jeux
d'enfants s'étaient enfuis à des libyens
raison de quitter somme
raison pour se trouvait
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
et
voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on voit qu'ils ont fait
dites vous que la jambe vous brûlez les
verts
résident qui dirige membres qui joue
servent là
toute la
[Musique]
les cadets
il ya 15 ans
toujours plaisir
aucune envie
s'il le faut je veux rien
chanter là
nous change
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si nous
jean
chez vous
lachance
les secours
[Musique]
des monuments n'écrivait pas
bayonne 7
bâle
folie
on est sans voix depuis
jeunes au coeur du nom
[Musique]
lambert
un jugement qui te vois si j'ai tort
quand je le dis
le champ
jean
attendre
k
[Applaudissements]
jean
bon
je vous nous
une chanson
les secours
jean
oui
[Musique]
m
toi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui ça fait six ans
que nous sommes à marie
tu m'as donné de bon enfant tu sais
depuis ce petit veau
non content
je n'ai pas cessé
tu aimais
mais ce soir j'ai envie de dépôt
tablier
de me faire battre
[Applaudissements]
bonjour
sega
ce soir elle est
on met des mots
je commence
m
[Musique]
non
il n'ya plus que tes amis et le football
tu dois retourner
j'ai l'impression est une voix de plus
en moins que la mère de ses enfants
je ne te demande pas de m'offrir des
fleurs tous les jours
et de faire de temps en temps un geste
d'amour ce soit je veux encore une fois
tout retrouver prendre
petit jeu
et puis
c'est
danger
les gars
ce soir et la semaine
on met des mois
[Musique]
c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
mais
et
chanter
dans la rue ou à ça
chanter avec une radio des cassettes
chanter
quand on n'est pas bien dans sa tête
champ
chanter
en basse
rien leur hymne au chant
il ne passe à temps
et bravo échanges
et
offrir son d'histoire
cadeaux et chant
m
en été
non
[Applaudissements]
le chang'e 2
martin
[Musique]
oh
dillon
chaud
monsieur là
oui
[Musique]
chan
et
chat
m
[Musique]
j'ai deux
aidantes
tout ce qu'a dit qu'on a pleuré
non
le champ
t
cris la musique
méchant
ettori nettoie chez les
tu es
comme ça
jean
et cela
[Musique]
à
tu ressembles c'est toi tu ne sort que
la nuit petit vite comme un fou qui ne
sait pas faire demain tu as le coeur
d'un ange et le sourire d'un loup tu
joues avec la vie tu joues avec l'amour
et pour que tu joues
qui trichent avec le temps tu te seras
toujours et au fond tu t'en fous
non
tu as les yeux de l'homme que tous les
océans n'ont pas su retenir
tu as lu ces troubles
pour avoir eu le temps d'avoir des
souvenirs
tu as les yeux togo pour savoir où
ans la frontière du désir
qui sera jamais malheureux parce que tu
as des yeux
après
non
si tu allais
m
e
allah
qui dit que la mer
tu la tiens dans tes bras qu'elle ne te
fait pas peur
[Applaudissements]
qui dit que la musique tu là au bout des
doigts tu la connais par coeur
tu te dis aux monty tu dis même pas de
quoi pourvu qu'il y ait plus
[Musique]
tu peux me dire ce que tu veux parce que
tu as des yeux pas faible
demain
que je voulais
à
là
m
tu fais
les feux
dans tes bras
lima peine c'est la première chanson de
michèle torr elle était venue la chanter
il ya quelques mois elle est bien voulu
foule elle a bien voulu revenir jean
patrouille
je me mets à imiter les confrères donc
c'est pas possible
qu'est ce que je disais qu'elle va
chanter mais oui chère michèle torr la
première chanson quand elle avait 16 ans
yeah yeah yeah
[Musique]
on met ball
je t'aime
m
un peu
viens je soigne
ton coeur blessé je veux
c'est
quitte à qui
[Musique]
m
areva
tu
je t'aime
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
lui ne voit son monde
la petite amie de jeu
ton
oui
jamais
les
[Musique]
je donne
ça ce n'est ni toutes les deux
je ne
j'attendais
que je
on est bas
étape 1
oui
[Musique]
le temps